[Music]
in sadistic shownu's Oh submitted by
hand down man down okay a new reality
show makes contestants eat animals and
they've spent time raising as pets
that's a huge challenge in Russia in
China not here here not here wait like a
cat and dog type pet or like they raise
pigs or what let's get the country Japan
I said China and I said Russia sorry
Australia India Africa Africa is not a
country but I'm just I'm like which one
I don't know geography very well on I
guess um Botswana
you said Ireland now you think you do I
did they did to a crush the Netherlands
okay so it's actually an Philippines are
1000 Britain it's a black mare [ __ ]
that's where they actually do a lot of
shut up really oh yeah that's why I said
that yeah but it sounds crazy to us but
this is what farmers and ranchers go
through all the time as pets
oh they don't eat your pet I mean I
don't have pets so I can't quite really
but yeah see I wouldn't eat like a cat
or a dog yeah it's already a meat that
you eat regularly it's it's not weird
Ray's a chicken and then eat it cuz i
watch this once racing is different than
bingling every morning like oh yeah i
watch this one show where this kazakh
all you see this page right here just
eyes gonna be so just delicious one day
his name's Jimmy and he's like honours
right here is all massaging his
shoulders that's all the same one he's
the butcher right Natalya butcher Jim
like um does he sleep like in a dog bed
by the end it Oh like a pet might as
well and trick they teach of children
adding on okay the way no there's no
like so sadistic I wouldn't care no if
you like whatever so this is a channel
for program Oh channel for huh yeah I
for you have a lot of good shows on that
time like our channel 4 or a channel 4
for them no they have the thing it's
kind of like seeing like is it like Fox
News further you can know so that's its
channel 4 but it's on channel 44
why like that channel for it it's like
58 or some [ __ ] okay a TBS or some [ __ ]
anyway Oh got it so this is a little
clip promoting the show it's called meet
the family dog the dog needs loving
families
I have joined one me a lot if you asked
me what we will do without meat look
like I'm taking them in for three weeks
girls welcome to you home once there
they must treat them like any other pet
if they stop eating meat and embrace the
vegetarian lifestyle then their animal
lives
[Applause]
only by vegan you know what what I
thought they were gonna do is have us
respect me and like like not make food
waste and [ __ ] probably didn't do that
this show would be so easy the moment
the animal pisses on your favorite rug
[ __ ] right now kill them it's a
show created by not meat eaters to try
to convince eaters to change their
habits I like it I need to watch the
show I need to be on this show yeah I
would lose the first day of cuz they're
like you got the challenges you gotta
eat vegetables the whole entire time or
else they're gonna get killed right I'm
eating meat the first day while watching
them and I'm like all right they're gone
I don't mind going vegetarian or vegan
at all I would enjoy that food and have
a happy life
but I just don't care that much about
like I don't have that much compassion
for animals of course if I see an animal
getting hurt or abuse I would never want
to see that but like I don't share the
same sympathies for like like I'm like
all that pig is really cute but I would
still eat it you don't be a pig lives
matter
yeah do but pigs are smart you could
teach them to read they can read at a
five-year-old level like a kindergarten
level okay a real challenge is they
raise that person to read their Bible
says that doesn't affect me though that
I don't care
I mean I'd I don't mean to be like
heartless heartless you're not because
I'm the same way and I get blamed for it
and it's this it's not bad yeah thank
you you guys outnumber the people that
are like oh I can't eat me because of
that like you guys are clearly like the
majority didn't eat delicious yet when I
made that connection and I think it like
things like this like made that
connection for me where you see like
them how they interact with you and like
how they're just like they're sweet and
they have souls I just couldn't do it
after that and I don't judge people that
eat meat at all like my husband eats
tons of meat but for me personally I
couldn't do it because it's just like so
[ __ ] sad I was like I I do like think
of them as
like a like give any anything that like
loves like that like a carrot or I know
people like that we have friends this
bodybuilding couple where they have all
kinds of goats and deer and all that
stuff and chickens and yeah once they
develop that bond with them you know
they're just like dogs all packed yeah
and they can't really eat Mina yeah
that's what I was saying earlier the
lorries and Ikey fishes because I've
never had a connection to fish like
they've never been a salmon that I'm
like oh this salmon loves me you never
would scuba diving and then kiss the
side maybe I'm a monster
you shouldn't feel it I just recently
saw his one video clip where there was
this guy like he has like scuba stuff
and I think he's working at a huge
aquarium or something and this gigantic
fish comes out to like a cat and starts
like doing this job and then he wanted
to get pet like that's the perfect point
to stab the salmon and eat him later
that's like padding this [ __ ] fish is
like a pufferfish those are those are
really cute and you could like they have
like personalities I'm like I can't eat
a pufferfish now and then I found out
lobsters hold hands and mate for life
I'm like I can't eat lobster either I
thought this whole show was gonna be you
got to raise your own animal and eat
that pet yes I get for saying oh it says
you you if you choose that yeah eat that
look no no it's what it says is that if
you can't go without eating meat then it
goes to the slaughterhouse yeah and it
gets eaten somewhere I love the same
thing is no I say you'll be forced to
eat their own pet he says what the
articles saying I don't remember what
the video says okay the video said that
didn't say to mention that yeah they're
saying that this these will be three
hour-long episodes and it will show the
reality of an animal's journey from
field to plates and highlight animal
behavior and intelligence the farming
practices required to meet the demands
of hungry consumers and the
environmental impact of producing meat I
do agree though that people have a huge
disconnect between like where their food
comes from and all that [ __ ] and they
need to see the reality oh yeah you're
eating an animal like if I could kill it
then I would I could eat it but I don't
think I could kill it so I can't eat it
that's true and that's pretty
responsible because people just don't
want to see it and they're like they
want to be
ignorant - that's right I want to be
ignorant yeah me too I think I could
kill it any day yeah well I'm crying I
could do it I wouldn't want to skin it
though that would be like see even
that's part of the process like a whole
chicken I can't do that that's kind of
gross I get this assistant to Joe Rob
Joe Rogan's latest podcast with this guy
named Cameron Hayes or Haynes so he's
like a super like one of the top of all
hunters it was cool to hear their ritual
where after they shoot an elk or
whatever they they get like a thing of
grass and they roll it up and they put
it on the elk and they all kind of bow
their heads take their hats off and say
a prayer like Avatar to kind of think
them for than me and - and also that's
kind of like the Elks like last meal and
they do their best to make sure they
like skinned and butchered the animal so
they take all the parts of it but it's
so cool to see that kind of respect
respect yeah yeah see that's why I like
I am NOT even against hunters that like
hunter me or anything the only thing I
don't like is factory farming like where
they're like stuffed in terrible
conditions and they're like they're
suffering the whole time like I think
that's [ __ ] up
yeah but yeah people that hunt and you
skin and get show respect and do all
that stuff yeah that's really cool
that's true cuz I love animals
but then I just can't stop getting that
taste out of my mouth I know what you
mean where I'm like I know you okay here
cute ass but like we'll go to the State
Fair why are the [ __ ] and the there's
these cows I mean in pigs and you're
like you're so yes such cute eyes eyes
and I start salivating and thinking
about ribs and then like you walk down
and you smell the chicken and barbecue
and you're just like oh you're
associating cuz like and I'm like you're
at a fair here smelling that and yeah
and I'm like damn I know damn I love you
but damn it's so good though and the
animals don't like disco the way I do
yeah I feel like this core thing good
what's your favorite disco song all of
Donna Summer as big as it
earth we did fire have you ever given a
pig a chance like this Co I look them in
the eye they didn't like them they can
develop taste you know but if they
started dancing I'd just be like that's
a delicious looking pigtail moves you
know it's like curly like a corkscrew
when they're dancing goes straight but
some pigs are ugly some animals are
gross
you know nay mean like they are not cute
like this clip show us some really cute
animals but plenty of animals are just
dicks try to commit suicide
what yeah cuz they get really depressed
cuz they can they understand like they
have the mind of like a five-year-old
right so like they understand being
separated from their mom there were like
really sad they're in solitary
confinement you know and they try to ram
them at their heads against the wall
that's why we need free-range pigs huh
so they stay happy until the time that
you don't I'd be way more for that and
the factory like the ones in Hawaii that
people go hunting I saw babe I remember
asking my mom like or kuzzik you know
how they they talk about like how baby
was gonna get slaughtered and like
because of me on stuff I remember
there's one moment where I was like mom
I don't ever want to eat pig I want to
eat babe and then the next meal I think
it was just a bacon you would like pork
or some - I can't eat this you gave her
a recipe I do yeah no I missed the she
ended up telling me like because I'd be
like oh so is did this come from a
bigger room she's like no it's got me
like meat like it's just neat so like I
grew up not really associating meats to
animals oh yeah because it's just like
this meat is just meat it's not like an
animal like I don't know it's kind of
hard to explain but I'm from that moment
when I was little and watching things I
see yeah that's why I like for the
Mexican like I don't eat that like
lengua and all that stuff I'm just like
I don't know what animal comes from it's
meat
that's right thing I started getting
more of a connection to the actual
animal once we started barbecuing
because then I started to understand
like the cuts of meat I'm like all cool
ribeye is from under this part it's
under the rib flap or whatever and then
the top seller and a bottom sirloin and
that's when I first started associating
all the different cuts of meat with the
different body parts whereas before it
was just like a cute cow and then like a
delicious steak but I didn't really see
that the state came from the cow because
we would go to the
like petting or color or whatever and be
like chickens and and when I'm eating a
chicken my mom would be like that's the
chicken's leg that you saw earlier and
what I oh cool oh my god fishing and
then my dad would be like hungry at the
fair yeah and we'll go fishing and my
dad will be like all right come here I'm
gonna teach you how to clean the fish
and we'll cut it cut it
everything so since I did it since I was
so little I never was scared of it or
maybe I was grossed out but then it was
just all taught that's true I saw my dad
butchered kicked chickens and fish in
our own house all the time yeah I guess
this guy just got under your house feels
so sad and delicious smells great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]